[موسيقى]
امين
منذ عام
10730 وهذه العائله تعمل في صناعه السفن
التقليديه في ولايه الصور في سلطنه عمان
حيث تتوارث الاجيال هذه المهنه التي تشتهر
بها السلطنه لا سيما في المناطق الساحليه
[موسيقى]
تقريبا احنا نكون اخر جيل
ماسكين المهني هذه ولايه صور طبعا
باقي المناطق ما عاد فيها شيء خلاص
المصانع اول كانت اكثر من نصنع الحين اخر
مصنع في سلطنه عمان يمكن في الخليج اخر
مصنع
صناعات خشبيه او يدويه
[موسيقى]
نحن هنا في اكبر هيكل لسفينه تقليديه في
سلطنه عمان هذه السفينه بدا العمل عليها
بدايات عام 2020 ومن المتوقع ان يتم
الانتهاء منها في اواخر العام المقبل
تكلفه هذه السفينه حوالي مليون دولار
امريكي
[موسيقى]
طبعا بالنسبه للسفينه ديه اكبر سفينه
وصناعتها من اكبر صفه طولها تقريبا
35 متر اللي هو يعادل تقريبا فوق 70 دراه
فوق تقريبا من 50 الى 55 متر
نوعيه الاخشاب
اغلى انواع السائق او اغلى انواع
متوفره كانت من افريقيا
[موسيقى]
هذه المهنه تواجه الكثير من التحديات
ابرزها انتشار السفن المصنوعه من مواد
حديثه مثل الفايبر جلاس بالاضافه الى عزوف
الشباب العماني عن هذه الصناعه
والله شيء
احنا الصناعات التي ربينا عليه حرام
من الحكومه الاساسيه
[موسيقى]
يضم هذا المصنع ورشه متخصصه بصناعه التحف
والمشغولات الخشبيه بالاضافه الى صاله
لعرض نماذج المصغره للسفن بكافه احجامها
وانواعها عبد الرحمن العصيمي من ولايه
السور العربيه
[موسيقى]